well family is also what Christy Teegan
and John Legend are all about this and
like many moms and dads the legends have
experienced a familiar parents rite of
passage the first parent teacher Col
Bruce it's kind of like a little therapy
session because if you want to have them
know they're not really there's not a
lot to tell us Chrissie posted this pic
of John looking comfy in a tiny chair
we're happy to report Lunas doing well
in preschool you know her teachers well
we love them we caught up with the
legends at the Wall Street Journal
magazine innovator Awards in New York
last night where the Olsen twins made a
rare public appearance and John was
honored with the entertainment innovator
award we know
Krissi's never misunderstood she told us
she's super careful with her comments on
social media like when a fan recently
slammed her for not breastfeeding well
she left it on John's Instagram that you
don't breastfeed never did actually does
she actually edit herself a little tame
Wow Chrissy news to report
first up Congrats to the newly engaged
Meg Ryan on melon hype she's been
spotted around New York rocking a ring
but today she confirmed the news on her
Instagram along with this cute sketch oh
I'll see your cute kilt and raise you
adorable Gabrielle Union and Dwyane Wade
have welcomed a little baby girl to
their family Gabrielle shared this sweet
skin-to-skin photo on her Instagram with
the caption quote our miracle baby
arrived last night via surrogate welcome
to the party sweet girl knew that
glimmer of sunshine today
congratulations Mom and Dad
[Music]
[Applause]